did you ever have that situation where
you kind of started to question yourself
like
because i know you know
the old conventional way of this [ __ ]
was hey we need it we need a single to
pop you off
that that was my whole i felt like that
was the whole beginning of my career
where i felt like i was constantly
questioning myself
and my own abilities because it wasn't
working and i'm like what am i doing
wrong what am i doing wrong
i'm constantly going back to the to the
drawing board and trying to reinvent or
come up with something else or mimic
what they're telling me i should be like
you know what i'm saying
and i got to a place where i was like
i don't know what what happened really
but i got charged up like you know when
you just
you stop taking [ __ ] and you just like
yeah you know what you got i got so
angry that it it forced me to no longer
seek no validation
and just pour that into myself like yeah
like it's almost like you're here for a
reason
it's because you're dope like just yeah
just
beat do you took the fun out of it yeah
cause then it feels like a job because
then you're not creating for the love or
for yourself you're creating for what
you think people want to hear
exactly and then i when i got back to
the basics like
when i got out of the label situation
and i had nobody just my friends
we were going to the studio every day um
you know just recording as friends
and i'm like you know this is fun this
is hot this is why we did it in the
first place
this is what this used to feel like so
now i just chase that like as long as
i'm having a good time and i'm i'm
around
good people good energy and i protect
that vibe i don't work with everybody
because you can't get that way